daniel's in columbia south carolina hi
daniel welcome to the ramsay show
hello dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
all right so um i'm in baby step six um
i'm 27 and my wife's 25
basically my mom reached out to me um
asking for
help um she had a lease a
police and she want to pay it off and
basically
it ended up the lease ends up this month
um and she asked me to to borrow
from me to to 2k
and basically um she asked me not to
tell my wife and obviously
you know we are we have join's account
and also um what's your question
yeah what what's your advice in my
situation
i don't do anything that i can't tell my
wife
anything ever if i'm in a meeting and
they say
all the discussion in this meeting has
to stay in this room you can't tell your
wife i get up and leave the meeting
there are no things on this planet that
i can't tell sharon
that is against the law at ramsey world
it will get your throat cut by your wife
while you're asleep dude
you can't be hiding crap from your wife
hello is that right yeah yes i'm trying
i mean your mom is out of control
where's your dad are they divorced yeah
no they're
they are together they have separate
accounts and actually my dad
let him let her 10k
to pay off he lent his own wife money
yes that's strange
okay so uh mom i can't do anything that
i love you but i can't do anything that
i can't tell my wife and don't ever
suggest that again
because it's not gonna it's not a
profitable conversation for us to have
okay mom can't do that and if you need
uh
two thousand dollars you need to talk to
your husband my dad
and you guys need to work on your
finances and get them get them combined
and get them straightened out
but i i think your mom i think your mom
is trying to hide
all of this from everybody and still
trying to find a way to snake her way
through this
and it's time that the cards are played
a face up on the table
mom is getting ready to be exposed and
needs to be
yeah needs to be so she needs to talk to
your dad and she and your dad have got a
lot of work to do
but you don't need to get involved in
the sun you just lovingly say no i don't
hide things from my wife and i
really think you need to talk to dad
about this he's got the money and you
guys have the money and you all need to
fix this
so sorry can't do it love you mom love
you mom
no chance